[Musique]
bon le cheval a tout de suite patron ne
soit pas si pressés nous nous les amis
m'attendre ce qu'ils vont être contents
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
bonsoir les enfants vous aussi vous
allez être très content car nounours
vous a réservé une belle surprise
bonsoir le petit
[Musique]
oui une nouvelle histoire très jolie
l'histoire d'une petite fille alors je
me pose
[Musique]
il y avait une fois il n'ya pas très
longtemps une petite fille ronde et
coquine que son papa et sa maman appelez
philippines au visage
[Musique]
un jour alors que sa maman tricotait
assises dans leur jardin et que
philippines était en train de manger le
grosse tartine de confiture de frein
elle vit passer un lapin blanc à tous
lapin ado lapin cria philippines mais le
lapin blanc parti en courant et
philippine se mit à le pourchasser en
criant
et la maman de philippine qui avait fini
son tricot se mit à la recherche de sa
petite fille ronde et coquine
et ne la trouvons pas rentrer a dans sa
maison très inquiète si le papa de
philippines 13 ans qu leur disais mais
où est-elle machine
lorsqu'on frappe à la porte c'était un
agent de police qui ramenait la petite
fille qui
parce qu'elle est à nos elle pleurait
parce que la vraie fin ce garnement de
lapin blanc avait mangé toute la tartine
de confiture de frein c'est bien fait et
après nous philippines fit un bon repas
que lui avait préparé sa maman pour la
consoler et elle se couchant et en
s'endormant elle murmure un auto lapin à
temps et le lendemain matin
le long de momentum
qui s'est passé je ne me rappelle plus
j'ai oublié d'apporter la suite
je vous la porterez une prochaine fois
je vous laisse le libre vous êtes
content elle est très jolie
pas d'apport de là c'est promis allons
les enfants ou les cris
une
bonne nuit les petits
la
gt-r
fait deux tours
[Musique]
patron si vous aviez vu leur joie le
cher petit n était très joli ton
histoire oui oh je l'aurais fait cadeau
du livre où s'en va en route bonne nuit
tous nos amis fêtes de bourg
[Musique]
non